I've been in Litchfield for a while now
and I have started to feel unsafe they
leave the time has come your calls
you're all taken care of we made another
season of the TV show TV fans rejoice or
just the new black is finally coming
back and et has everything you need to
know about season 4 including Piper's
new problems and then the season 4
trailer that we've seen she gets herself
into a lot of trouble of tease what's
coming on she is trying so many
different things to be ok this year
she's not making the best decisions but
she's trying let's talk about her love
life are we gonna have one this year I
don't know I think it's changing a
little bit
you saw a teen time that she's be a
for-profit prison now I got a hundred
new inmates I'm buying yeah oh you know
any type of new meat is always
interesting in the prison system it
always changes the dynamic and this
season is definitely gonna it's gonna be
a little rough it's a lot of changes I
know there's some it feels crowded and
claustrophobic I like my territory so I
will rise against that
however they are formidable in their
size and dimension so stay tuned orange
is the new black is the first series to
receive any nominations in both comedy
and drama categories but the cast
reveals season 4 is the darkest one yet
it's very dramatic it's kind of dark
it's it's confusing you know and I think
that's where or we're out of the line
it's not so much like that black and
white drama commented it's like Matt
it's like confusion which is what life
is it's confusing it's a dramedy it
still is but there are a lot of dark
moments I think that people are going to
be surprised at how dark we're going to
go you know I just watch to view the
evidence and I think that it really does
lean more towards the
drama end of the spectrum this season
but there's still a tremendous amount or
it's still really really funny